sur ces petits drones des soldats
Ukrainiens attachent des bombes
miniatures
objectif toucher à distance les
positions russes depuis le crâne
nous les pilotons pas seulement jusqu'à
la frontière russe mais beaucoup plus
loin dans leur territoire parce que
c'est de la bas qu'ils tirent leur
missile
ce n'est pas comme leur bombardement
on cherche et on cible uniquement leurs
armes qui attaquent nos villes
d'autres drones servent simplement
d'appareils de reconnaissance et désigne
ensuite les cibles au lanceur de
missiles Kiev se fournit auprès de la
Turquie et des États-Unis une nouvelle
technique dans la guerre utilisée aussi
par les forces du Kremlin depuis
plusieurs semaines
pour lancer des engins kamikazes sur
l'Ukraine
l'agresseur continue cette erreur nous
sommes à nouveau attaqués depuis le ciel
par une volée de leur corbeaux plus de
30 drones ont été lancés en deux jours
de pénétrer à l'arrière du pays chaque
raid selon plusieurs experts militaires
la Russie ne possédait pas de drones de
longues portées avant la guerre qui est
accuse Moscou d'avoir passé des commande
massives ces dernières semaines
notamment à l'Iran la Russie a
officiellement commandé 2400 drones mais
on ne sait pas si ce nombre peut être
produit c'est probablement la raison
pour laquelle l'intensité des attaques
russes au drone a été quelque peu
réduite ces derniers jours selon Kiev
les forces militaires ukrainiennes ont
abattu près de 300 drôles russes depuis
le début du mois de septembre